hi and welcome to episode number
thirteen of the weekly Google cloud
platform podcast I'm Franciscan boy and
then joined today by my colleague mark
Mendell hey Mark hey Francis can you do
it today pretty good very excited about
this amazing episode we're gonna be
talking about firebase finally yeah it's
gonna be a really good great way to come
back from my vacation talk about a
wonderful topic exactly well for you
yeah you had vacations yeah yeah but
before that we have a cool thing of the
week and it's actually related to one of
the things that we talked about last
episode which is about training nice so
it's uh we have a bunch of trainings
coming on and they're gonna be happening
very soon actually so today's Wednesday
17th so it's actually tomorrow and some
of them are tomorrow better get on that
quickly yeah and they're really cool so
you can go to cloud.google.com /
training and you'll find a bunch of
courses some of them are in New York in
the Google office some of them are in in
sunnyvale next month of you so these are
actually like classes yeah go to them
there's a trainer all that sort of stuff
yeah and they're like one whole day of
going around Google platform so it's
actually cb100 which is the Google
platform platform fundamentals nice know
if you're looking to get started with
Google cloud platform this could be a
really great way to get up to speed
quickly I know that I've attended as a
student these classes and and I thought
it was amazing you get to play with all
the little pieces of a Google cloud
platform you don't go too deep into
those but you just get an idea yeah what
is the power what can you do with the
answer so if you're looking to build
something you kind of go away and you're
like oh now I know a little bit about
everything so I can sort of build
together a picture of exactly how I want
to build something yeah and even cooler
than that so not everybody lives in New
York or especially not everybody's in
sunnyvale district so we also have
online classes and
they're online classes that are actually
happening live so you will be able to
ask questions and so on yeah so trying
to bring the the class experience to the
two people all around the world and
they're also happening februari 18th and
19th so just go there you will have to
register but it's gonna be really cool
you're gonna basically go through the
same same concept it's also see be 108
so Google cloud platform fundamentals
but from the comfort comfortable couch
in your house if you want to yeah you
can sit on your bed you could be in a
couch yeah I mean even do it in jacuzzi
like we don't judge that's really fancy
I yeah that gives me as I should try to
do that next don't drop your laptop into
the jacuzzi yeah that would be bad good
fine ok so as we said we're going to be
interviewing two awesome people yes yes
our robinson and Vikram Nisha Vikram
najar from both from firebase Sarah now
working with us in our team yep and
we're gonna be talking about firebase so
let's go with that let's do it today we
are joined by two wonderful guests that
are here today to talk to us about
firebase we've been talking about it for
a little while but it's great to have
two people to come talk to us about it
directly we have both sarah robinson and
Vikram measure thank you very much for
joining us today thanks for having us
thanks for having us now I did manage to
mess up your last names I'm very
well-known doing that that was bought on
its butt on right great great all right
wonderful so before we get stuck into
things do you want to give us a bit of
background on yourself so people know
who you are sir why don't we start with
you sure my name is sarah robinson i'm
currently a developer advocate on the
Google cloud platform team with mark and
Francis and before that I was a
developer advocate on the firebase team
with Vikram cool so Sarah and I have
worked together for a few years now I'm
Vikram I'm on the sre team at firebase
so I sorry in Google parlance is sort of
like a DevOps operations engineering for
up time for firebase the service go so
we've been talking about firebase
many episodes yeah we thought I OT on
cloud spin basically every single
episode we say there is fire base we
should talk a little bit more about on
that in detail at some point and today's
a day so why don't you become tell me a
little bit what is firebase so firebases
mission statement is to help developers
build extraordinary experiences so we in
a nutshell provide a service that lets
you spin up your app and get started
with the least amount of work and we
make it easy for iOS Android and the web
so it's mostly for for mobile its web
and mobile so we've got three client
libraries JavaScript client for the web
and then iOS and Android clients for
mobile and then it's also a REST API
cool so what what can you do with it so
essentially there's three core features
that are part if i erase the first is
the real-time database which is also my
favorite so it's a no sequel JSON
database and every piece of data in
firebase is referenced by URL so it
makes it really easy to write data
directly from the client and the really
cool thing is that all the updates
happen in real time so any client that's
connected to a firebase application will
see changes to that data right as it
happens they don't have to refresh the
page or pulled a refresh on mobile so
there's a big WOW factor their dads rina
that's one of the things that I really
like and the cool thing for me is that
you don't need to do it with one of the
libraries you can also use the rest api
so you can use it with go which is
always nice and then the second second
product that we have is a static hosting
so this is essentially a website but it
gives you a rare domain CDN and as a
cell at the push of up man so it's
really magical in how easy it is to get
set up yeah just one command firebase
deploy and then your app is live on its
own firebase opcom URL which is pretty
cool that's right nice so your gums with
https directly yeah man wow yeah you
don't have to worry about acquiring the
cert right yeah I saw that that's really
cool that is really cool and then the
third feature is authentication so if
you ever implemented Oh off
very fun procedure firebase luckily
takes care of all that for you so we
support a number of different providers
so you can authenticate users with
Facebook Twitter github google more
email password login or authentication
or anonymous authentication and you just
need to freezing one of the third party
providers just enter your API key and
secret into the ear firebase dashboard
and then you can start authenticating
users directly from the client vertical
that actually makes writing applications
much easier because I know that 1 i'm
writing an application the worst bar is
when you're like ok now i need to add
authentication because i want to be safe
and yeah it's always fun yeah it off to
dance and like yeah no i don't like it
yeah with firebase is just one method
call and JavaScript off with OAuth pop
up and then we've got user
authentication and yeah yeah so the
theme along like all of those three main
offerings that we have is to try to move
people as fast as possible for their app
without having to worry about servers
and and I started getting wrapped around
hacks all with getting those set up and
provisioned it's scaling them we try to
handle for you very nice so I live for a
little bit of context of how how will
these firebase how how many years has
puts its history yeah I was the history
so we've been a so google acquired
firebase in October 2014 and firebase
got its start during the summer of two
thousand eleven while James and Andrew
the co-founders were going through Y
Combinator and it's a little known fact
I know I guess it is a large enough act
that so the same batch that we went
through media also went through that
batch nice parts also went through the
batch and then we're also in that batch
so there is three sort of client back
end is a servant sort of offerings all
through YC during the summer of two
thousand eleven cool and how did how did
the company evolve like how do you start
why did you start building these and why
do you have those three features how do
you decide what type to firebase so they
were actually going through I see with a
complete
the different company yeah so it was a
company called involve actually that was
a chat service so this is a sort of a
business where you can add chat to your
website with without having to worry
about servers okay and the common
drumbeat that we got from our paying
customers at the time was well can we
add like game data on top of this chat
bus can we add comments and and so
there's this recurring theme that that
people wanted to have real-time features
without having to architect it or build
it and it was around that time that we
decided to sort of generalize that
offering into a real-time database so we
started out with just the database that
summer and and sort of focused just on
that part of it the hosting and
authentication came a couple years later
but we just focused on the database at
that time one way that that firebase
grew its user base really early on he
was talking directly to the developers
that were using it from the start so I
know even before I join you you guys
went to a ton of hackathons and would
try to get feedback and see how people
were using the API and then iterate on
the BF in there yeah so we actually
wrote no lines of code before we started
doing feedback so Andrew had mocked out
documentation for a hypothetical API and
told people hey if you were to write an
application with this set of API is what
would it look like so we got a lot of
feedback around the ergonomics of the
API before we even wrote any code just
to flesh out like it is this something
that can be readily consumed and and so
we did hundreds of hours of video
interviews with developers like once the
API did get flushed down once an SDK did
exist and and that was one of the the
core tenants of how we kept the
developers interest so tightly in focus
because if you know you're you're sort
of in a vacuum and you're hacking away
and you think this is cool it doesn't
really matter if it's
if it's not solving your development
problems and we had a very regimented
approach to doing developer feedbacks
which included actually like videos and
like reviewing the videos and not having
to worry about taking notes like when
we're doing developer feedbacks yeah I
was always really surprised when you're
almost ready to launch a new feature we
would go through round of developer
feedbacks and find that there was a lot
of things that we just didn't even think
about um really that were revealed
through the feedback sessions well this
is a fully lunch yeah that's interesting
because I know that a lot of companies
do that kind of product management and
make market studies and so on for none
software stuff like before you design
something that is hard work you let
people play with it and see how they do
it but I've have not heard about that
same technique for a fee ice which is
actually a very good idea real like it
makes a lot of sense yes a lot of sense
so you're talking about talking directly
with customers what are some of the cool
things you saw people building with far
away so I have seen people building with
firebase what sort of cool examples can
we find so one of my favorite to talk
about is Warby Parker there a glasses
company and they let you order your
glasses online and then they send you a
couple you choose which ones you like
and then send back the rest they have a
physical store in New York and that
store has pneumatic tubes so when you
order your glasses at the register their
shot down to via pneumatic tubes and
their tubes notifications are actually
powered by firebase I have will be cut I
have will be pocket classes yeah those
glasses are powered by fairies are you
know it's a regional of them spinning on
put them in the San Francisco store okay
okay I feel bad that is very very cool
what about you they have one yeah so my
favorite firebase app is an app called
roll20 so this is a tabletop gaming app
that Riley the founder has been with us
essentially since the beginning and I
love gaming it's a platform built on
firebase for gaming it connects people
with one another to not only build games
uh for themselves but also play with
others
um and it's one of the use cases where
yeah with a very small team he was able
to leverage our technology to build his
product so yeah roll20 net yeah I was
out looking at that right now looks
pretty cool looks like a very cool game
and assoc has that chat yeah yeah and
there's a there's a case study on the
firebase oh yes I ya know I've read that
before and it's really cool I really
stuff like this especially in the gaming
space i especially like because of the
fact that you've got the real-time
updates across web iOS android so you
can have that sort of cross-platform
approach which is really really powerful
yeah I think the thing that we as
developers and engineers we we sort of
lose sight of how ubiquitous
technologies like real time there's a
lot hidden behind the details right just
because we see it in Google Docs and
spreadsheets all the time or we see it
in hangouts yeah doesn't mean it's very
accessible to every developer right like
we have huge teams of people that are
you know building out hangouts and
Google Docs and and so by having this
feature set in firebase we give
developers the ability to to build those
sorts of features in their products yeah
makes that real-time accessible that
maybe just a single developer or small
startup yeah that's actually very very
very interesting point the fact that it
looks easy but it is not know how how is
it done can you can you talk a little
bit about this secret sauce what's going
on in the firebase servers yeah so at at
a very high level we fan out this JSON
as Sarah mentioned to develop our SDKs
that are plugged into their applications
right so at a very high level that sort
of what we're doing nuts and bolts of it
are whether it's a browser that's
connected or an iOS device we have in
the wide majority of cases a persistent
socket that's connected to our servers
and then we handle the fan out of JSON
between all of those connected sockets
even lower
we have written so the the core firebase
server is written in Scala we use the
awesome Neddy networking pipeline to
handle web sockets to handle rest like
Sarah mentioned we have a long polling
implementation where for browsers that
that don't support web sockets we fall
back to it's all custom implemented
Scala that's backed by disk elsewhere
but for most part of the magic happens
in our JPM process cool I think that
that might be the first time I hear
about something bringing Scala at Google
hmm i don't think yeah i don't know but
anyone else the desk scholar so you have
scala on the JVM then you're a necessary
for that yeah yeah that's right that's
pretty unique interesting very
interesting that's very cool alright so
I we were talking a little bit
previously about sort of gaming in
firebase um I got particularly excited I
saw there was a recent unity unity 3d
plug-in so people are aware unity to an
engine for doing games in both 3d and 2d
so there's a unity plugin for firebase
to do real-time event accreditation
stuff can you tell us more about that
that's pretty exciting yeah so it's it's
an early preview so you can find access
to it in our google group so if you go
to the firebase google group the public
one and search for unity you'll see one
of our engineers made call out to to be
able to take a look at one of the early
examples we've we've had a steady
drumbeat of requests for unity is
essentially since the beginning not
surprised yeah and like Sarah mentioned
earlier our first SDK was JavaScript the
second and third ones were iOS and
Android and unity you know for the most
part runs on C sharp and the way that
the architecture there is we didn't have
like a simple plugin that we could have
added without a lot of heavy lifting um
and so even though you remained a
priority we didn't have the bandwidth to
to execute on that early on and it was
once we joined
Google that you know we we had the
engineering resources to be able to to
build something to allow people to use
firebase on on unity it's still early
days so I don't have any examples off
the top of my head of people that have
built games on it yet that was my next
question sir but soon you need is huge
across all platforms and and giving both
like indie developers and N and big
shops the ability to add those sorts of
features to their games we realize is
extremely important now that you mention
in developers there's something that I
really like about firebase which is it's
actually free for many cases like what
is the pricing I know that the free tier
is very nice yeah it's essentially free
forever up to 100 concurrent connections
so that means like 100 simultaneous
people on your website or mobile app at
the same time which is actually a lot so
it's probably a good problem to have
yeah a hundred people in your app at the
same time yeah that's that's right now
is that basically takes you all ready to
the point where well maybe I should
start making money or nothing yeah yeah
that very good if you got 100 concurrent
people yeah you're not making money I'll
get my web page has a bad guy no and
then on the free tier you also get
access to firebase hosting so you can
deploy to your own firebase app com
domain and then the self-service pay
plans start at forty nine dollars forty
nine dollars a month and then the
concurrent limits kind of go up from
there nice there is also a spark plan
which is five dollars a month okay yeah
I'd like to give you the customer in
that custom domain we heard a lot of
feedback we're 49 was too high for the
indie developers now whereas the free
gives you some things the the five
dollar plan gives you your own white
labeling and and some of the features of
the higher plan so we heard that
feedback from from the indie devs we
have a five dollar plan as well nice
nice that's crazy gay coffee here in San
Francisco cool so you mentioned that so
some time ago you were together with
ours
as in the same batch for YC community y
combinator later on you've got acquired
by google pars got acquired by Facebook
we all know pars ended up being shut
down well at some point and the
migration was great but still some
developers felt like oh yeah like this
was a problem what can you say to those
that might be a little bit concerned
about this happening to firebase so in
general is it was very sad right the
shutdown of of parse and you know we we
know that team it's just bad for the
ecosystem at large let alone for the
developers and the parse team which
which we know and you know and there
there are many apps that were built on
parts and fire based and firebase and
meteor and so it's not you know they're
not completely siloed I think the thing
to keep in mind is what these sorts of
offerings provide whether it's firebase
or parse is is leverage for developers
to build their products and build their
visions and as long as there are there's
a need for that I think this ecosystem
will continue to exist in flourish
whether the particular circumstances
around parse can be dissected I think
it's pretty unambiguous that Google
supports cloud in general yeah and
developers in particular yeah I know
there's lots of exciting firebase
features that the team is working on I'm
Google is definitely a hundred percent
behind firebase so yeah so yeah so stay
tuned we have we have a lot to announce
at Google i/o whoo any right well I have
to ask you might say no but I like is
there anything you could maybe like hint
at or any new features that we could
possibly get a little scoop on just here
the only stuff i know is confidential so
uh the same III just say that I think
I'll just reaffirm Google's commitment
to firebase once you see what what gets
announced and released that I oh I think
there will be no doubt as to the
commitment and and longevity which is
sort of envisioned full of firebase
great stay tuned yeah I know that I
visiting our team developerworks you for
cloud we are not forced to talk about
firebase like it's something that is
there but we choose to use it yes cuz
it's awesome yeah it's gonna be going
away anytime soon so all right we've
covered seems like a lot of things about
firebase is there anything that you
wanted to mention about firebase that
hasn't been mentioned already or
anything that's particularly amazing
about it you want to kind of highlight
actually the integration between a
firebase and cloud is recently there was
an Android studio update release that
makes it really easy to integrate
firebase in to your android app you can
just do it directly through the android
studio interface and we've got a
tutorial on how to do that you can
actually add an app engine back into
your firebase app so we'll put that in
the show notes nice nice what would you
become yeah so so one of the questions I
always get you know whether it's related
with parts or firebase and you know how
how much we love using it is so I have a
lot of like friends and family who I've
evangelize firebase to and so like I'm
on the SRT team and like you know when
when things aren't working like all get
my personal calls to my personal phone
saying that what's wrong with the server
as i get it back up so like I just
wanted to you know let people know that
service availability and uptime and and
the areas around a magical Cloud Service
being up our first and foremost on you
know our our team's priorities and and I
hear from those from my brother and my
close friends who are also using
firebase I really like the five legs
like sra but it's not only about okay
yards and keeping it safe is like
otherwise your family will shut up yeah
friends yeah that you have an outage
good as your moms rap is down that's
good that's good well thank you very
much Sarah and Vikram for joining us who
really appreciate you taking the time to
talk to us about firebase today thanks
for having us yeah it's been a pleasure
thank you so much thank you thank you so
thank you very much again to sana and
Vikram for being here with us today I
really off the conversation I learned a
lot about firebase and also the way they
do things I'm very interesting the way
they they do their product management
definitely definitely liked it so we
actually asked a question which was a
delicate question of the week delegation
anyway like that like which was about
yeah so uh so parse would shut down what
about firebase were the plans and so on
and we actually found right after
finishing the interview with them that
James Tamplin of one of the cofounders
of firebase wrote a blog post on the
firebase blog about about the shutdown
of pars and the future plans of fibers
are Google so if you're interested in
that I think it's a very great weed it
gives a bunch of links to other things
what they're working on they actually
also mentioned the unity plug-in that
you were so interested about so I think
it's a great read if you want to know
more about it yeah definitely and if
you're interested to see like to sort of
a snapshot clients of what they've been
up to with firebase and what's of ideas
they've got coming up in the future it's
a good read yeah definitely definitely
have a look in the show notes obviously
of course cool and before we finish with
this amazing episode I think we should
go for the question of the week question
of the week okay great so we're we're
talking about this before actually
amongst ourselves we're talking about so
all right obviously you've got the cloud
console you know if you have a laptop
you sit down you can have a look at
everything that's going on inside your
google cloud platform project but what
do you do if say you're traveling or
addition generally more mobile you know
you don't have access to a laptop what
do you do in an instant so there's a
couple options the first one is trying
to access the console with your browser
on a mobile phone and you will see that
it's actually not a great great option
works a good dozen it's not incredibly
responsive let's okay but that's
actually not a big problem because
there's a much better option which is we
have native native apps for both iOS and
Android which actually they're just call
Google Cloud console on both the Play
Store and the apps are yeah we'll have
links to both is in the show notes but
now we were both sort of playing with
them and having a look at them in there
they're really nice say you have an
incident like something goes down you're
using cloud monitoring which you should
be obviously yep and you want to see
what's going on you've got direct access
to that incident see what it is you've
got access to your logs you can see
charts and reports on what your
resources are doing yeah anyways even if
everything is going on normally and
everything is perfect I personally like
to go and see the graphs like oh yeah
everything is up you can see if your
machine crash for any reason you have
access to all the logs and so it's it's
pretty nice to have and then there's
this thing that we were watching me is
like a minute ago and it just blew my
mind it's evil it's basically I was on
my android app I I'm assuming the iOS
app also does it but I'm not really sure
but on the Android app I went to one of
my machines and then I clicked on the
little burger menu and I saw one of the
options with ssh into this machine which
is pretty freaking amazing yeah yeah
suddenly we had an ssh terminal on our
mobile phone connecting to a compute
engine instance me like oh now we can
just SSH around yeah be also so next
step you need a hater the keyboard oh
are you really or maybe you're just
really good at typing yeah and yeah but
yeah really really amazing i'm very
excited about this and actually i'm
gonna be using it much more now that i
know i can ssh into my cloud instances
from anywhere in the world yeah now I
really love it yeah very cool so yeah
well we'll have a bunch of links to both
apps and I'm actually gonna be tweeting
about this because I have the snapshot
and it's just amazing it's really cool
yeah very excited wonderful alright well
I've been away for a little while France
esque why don't you update me on where
you're gonna be in the
x coming weeks so I'm actually gonna be
in a bunch of places so on friday i'm
flying to Dubai I'm going to Dubai for
gopher come see ya yeah there's gopher
come to buy so it's the newest go
conference in the world yeah right now
there is gopher con India there is
happening right now go for con device
right after and i'll be i'll be there
for two days and after that what else i
actually am planning on traveling too
much other than in march will be south
by southwest and then back to San
Francisco for gcp next very very nice I
think my travel stuff is still pretty
much the same with the launch hackathon
on the 26 of februari from there
everything's pretty much in California's
nice i'll be a game developer conference
I'll be helping out at the booth I'll
definitely be there so if you're there
please come say hello I will be a JCP
next as well which I'm super excited
about and also be a su strada nice doing
some fun stuff they're very very cool so
I think that before we leave I think
it's always a good thing to do which is
going through all the ways people can
contact us yes because we love questions
we love comments I love everything so
okay I'm gonna be the one asking the
questions alright so Twitter gcp podcast
um google+ app the plus G sine [ __ ]
Marcus we have a subreddit a / r / gcp
podcast and then our email hello at JCP
podcast.com and our webpage gcp podcast
com very easy to remember there you go
there you go so please send us stuff we
love to hear from you yep there's
nothing better than coming up to the
office on Monday morning and we I'm
seeing some emails from people saying
hey your podcast is awesome and a half
questions so say is I hate your [ __ ] is
not a good these ideas to how to improve
it we're open to both yes oh yes
constructive criticism is always welcome
but where we love we love the
interaction yep well so thank you so
much for coming back from Australia and
being
again with me today mark now thank you
very much for joining me as well Francis
and talk to you next week see you next
week
you